one thing that I could have done better
I wish I did better in my 20s it was
being more financially illiterate so
that I could take advantage of certain
things dude if I was a dancer and I
asked you for like like advice and you
hit me with that I'd be so [__]
bummed out yeah
[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys where we are
currently off the Record no one wants to
stay with me do you want all of us here
don't blame it on me I already did the
[__] lob it's like in volleyball when
you said it that's it you can't touch
the ball again
it's different every time sometimes Ryan
says it sometimes you point to the guy
next to you I don't I didn't know you
want all of us to say I thought we were
doing Like a Wheel of Fortune I was
trying to buy my own business and to be
honest I was about to fart and I was
wondering if I should do it hey
everyone's side still go ahead go ahead
go ahead like I feel but doesn't want to
come
yeah yeah all right try it again
[Laughter]
dude the [__] bubble went up the
[__] strong
[Laughter]
so what are you going to tell us about
how awesome Vegas is again no
I'm never gonna say [__] like that yeah
but you're totally you're totally
bragging about how you said forty
thousand dollars in taxes only in our
private group I didn't think you're
gonna make it public information
so in the group chat um recently we had
to do our 2022 taxes
um and in the taxes uh because I lived
in Nevada for a full year now I was like
yeah what would be my tax had I stayed
in California and I saved I think like
almost 47 000 wow that's a lot of money
what are you gonna use it for a raise
times two or three invest in your own
businesses sometimes two or three years
[__] as of like crazy you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah that's pretty
sweet that's only California
well Anthony doesn't want to go anywhere
he doesn't want to move to the states so
how's the water situation up there
though yeah pretty good not raining like
crazy the last six months so like Lake
Mead is like overflowing now
hey put it all put it all on black yeah
put it on black yeah you got the guts
did you do it what put it all on black
no I'm not Joe oh you don't want double
the money all right Joe's down this guy
doesn't like money God this guy hates
dogs he hates an opportunity I'm scared
of crazy [__] like that what is like a
an actual practical game plan though for
you when you're thinking like okay cool
like now I've saved this much by moving
out here I'm gonna use this money to we
know it's not reinvest into your
business but like what what are like
strategies uh so that was a strategy
when we um first thought about moving
because at that time
um when I talked with my accountant I
was like based off the last three years
can you estimate like how much I would
save and then they he said it's gonna
probably be anywhere from like 50 to
maybe even 100.
um so I was like okay cool so if I move
to Vegas and I hate it and I come back
in five years I would come back 200 to
almost 500 richer so I was like that's
that's worth it it's worth it just just
living somewhere else for five years if
I hate I'll just come back
um so this was the first year I was able
to kind of take like the empirical
evidence and then match it with what we
forecasted okay so you're getting proof
now this is how this is really
speculated and this is what happened
cool so pretty happy
why do you look so grumpy dude oh dude
we're not jealous we're jealous for sure
so how's the water those is
it's like you can only drink like one
cup a day
and Crystal Geyser they got all the same
Brands over there
there's only one pack a month how about
you how about you Nick how much have you
saved tax was now now that you have two
kids [__] nothing dude I'm getting
destroyed on Texas you haven't used your
pugs as deductions no I tried to and
they looked they laughed in my face they
looked at me like I was like you can do
it until you get audited yeah honestly
my biggest fear my biggest fear is
getting audited it sucks you seem like a
guy that's scared of being audited yeah
what flag the audit yeah
I don't even know that they tell you
what exactly the flags but um some of
the things some things I learned
recently is
um don't round up around down your your
numbers so let's just say for example
it's your the number is like 1230 and 67
cents but don't put 1230. oh so it Flags
just by being um you got to put the
sense put everything in because it'll
alert it Flags things um obviously if
you you know your accountant doesn't
want you to make money on paper for a
year or two so if you do it like I think
three plus years that Flags them oh uh
well Walter made zero dollars
you know but with deductions and stuff
you know it's actually it is it is it's
it's accurate it's accurate but it Flags
it Flags them so it's one of those
things they flat it got flagged they
audited and like okay there was no
wrongdoing here but no they oh that was
wrong well no there wasn't any
wrongdoing it's what
she wouldn't
um classify certain things as what we
classify their masks so your sex dolls
are not a business expense well sir I
try yeah for research I really tried but
she was like no it's not research
um you're just trying to have fun oh but
you don't know that no those are
emotional support dogs that's yeah
that's that's the tough part so and then
when there's and I had a stickler
auditor
and then so she actually increased the
amount of years I was audited
so rather than one year she increased it
to like I think three years no wow you
must have really talked back it's it's
sucked it's uh um yeah so getting
audited so like you know there's no
Rhyme or Reason other than you know just
bad luck bad timing because when I got
audited
it was less than one percent we're
getting audited now it's a little now
it's a little over one percent yeah I
totally do the artery yeah
I was there there is some though like if
like you're the IRS so you're also not
trying to audit people that like uh make
a lot of money no don't make a lot of
money right it would be like a waste of
time yeah exactly yeah because like
that's what they do get audited because
they can't fight it yeah they don't have
the fun stuff but you get hit you gotta
hit like a sweet spot in between right
it's like more than middle class than
anything for sure so like when they
audit like a multi-millionaire they can
afford tax attorneys like 20 tax
attorneys to fight against one yeah
they're trying to go they want they want
like small businesses so they like have
money to pay but don't have enough to
like change the scope of the auditor
that you had would you say like outside
of that situation you would hang out
with that person I never met the auditor
I didn't that's a good question you
wouldn't get them some with them yeah
she was a woman and she was a potential
Jerry because she's Southeast Asian yeah
um I won't say she's Vietnamese but um
yeah very she's a fam yeah okay actually
I think she was a fan how stressed were
you were you during this conversations
those email exchanges
um it wasn't more stress I was more like
upset yeah because because I was getting
accused of things that I wasn't doing
and then it wasn't actually it was not
even accused it's like basically you did
this this is what you did it's like no
yeah it's like no I didn't and then it
would disprove that you didn't do it
yeah so basically you're I felt like I
was guilty before yeah you know rather
than being innocent you know to proven
guilty what kind of things are those are
those very basic like you said you spent
this and you don't have a receipt for
example Asian Asian uh my Asian tour
um she's like you know how many uh
receipts that you got paid like look
that's not how they pay it's all cash
and he says no no I think you're lying
and then and there was a time when the
Laugh Factory the owner Laugh Factory
goes he told me uh Hey if you find a
venue out there I'll let you use Laugh
Factory name and open a club so I was
like cool so I told you it's a research
but you don't have anything written who
writes that like who what business is
gonna be like oh yeah hey I'm gonna
write you a letter that says hey go
ahead and open a club No One's Gonna do
that no you're lying like you just went
for vacation so so I couldn't write any
of that off and she was like I think
you're just lying about being a comedian
unless you can make me laugh right now
what joke would you tell her
um I would tell her like you know I
would say let's see uh oh say knock
knock knock who's there
got you huh
like we're gonna increase that to six
years
you're looking at molestation charges
I'm not Nick though I'm not Nick
I'm not a dick she's like who's there
she's like yeah you're right you're
right
she shows a picture of me yeah sorry
Walter you're not you're an option I
feel like honest for like small
businesses though
um is like it's like getting a speeding
ticket on the freeway like everybody's
speeding you just got caught that day
yeah you know what I mean so like even
the things that you're like getting in
trouble for whatever it's not like you
are [__] tax fraud like money
laundering like Mafia it's like you're
just doing certain business practices
that aren't like to the T or like you
know what I mean like beneficial because
everyone in the ecosystem technically
every small business starts off illegal
yeah because like if you're supposed to
do it the right way today's video is
brought to you by Lumi all right me to
tell you the truth I am not a deodorant
guy I used to wear deodorant all the
freaking time in high school until one
day someone told me you know that stuff
is harmful to you and I was like for
real so I did my research and I was like
yeah I couldn't believe it there's
Metals in there it's disgusting and on
top of that I'll even smell so I just
use cologne once in a while if I stink
but now that I'm religiously always
working out and I don't have time to
take a shower immediately after the gym
I just like wished I had something to
clear and freshen up just a little bit
but thank goodness we got Lumi here
which is a whole body of deodorant
it's a whole body deodorant meaning I
could just rub it on my forehead on my
armpit on my butt crack everywhere yeah
because originally it was invented by OB
GYN it was supposed to be for the hoo-ha
and you know that's a very sensitive
place and because it has to be perfectly
ph balanced for the hoo-ha it actually
works everywhere else so if you got
smelly Parts anywhere inner thigh under
boob armpit whatever they'll take care
of it at the source it doesn't cover up
the smell it prevents the smell from
even happening and like Joe said a lot
of other deodorants got some harmful
Metals but this one's aluminum free
paraben free baking soda free and it is
perfectly ph balanced used all over your
body my favorite smell is a clean
tangerine
but they also have fresh Alpine they
have very nice smells like lavender and
stuff like that you definitely gotta
check it out so if you're looking for
somewhere to start the Lumi starter pack
is perfect for new customers it comes
with a solid stick of deodorant the
cream tube deodorant and two free
products of your choice like the
deodorant body wash and the deodorant
wipes and on top of that you get a free
shipping that's a special offer for
listeners new customers get five dollars
off the starter pack with code OTR at
lumaydeodorant.com that equates to over
40 of your starter pack when you visit
Luminate deodorant.com and use the code
o t r you're technically supposed to pay
yourself as an employee right from the
start but that's your first way to save
money is I'm not paying not paying
myself I can get this thing [__] up
and running right so you're technically
already an unpaid worker and you're
supposed to like [__] suit yourself
for some [__] which is crazy yeah so
you're on LLC yeah it's [__]
impossible you know the tick tock thing
that's been going around about like oh
buy a G-Wagon yeah and then you get the
tax right on so that's my account about
it right and she goes okay what they're
neglecting to tell you is is that when
you go to because they say to buy a G
wagon because it retains its value and
then so when you go to sell it you can
you're only it only drops in a little
bit for what you pay for but my account
said is what they're neglecting to tell
you is when you sell it you have to
report that so then all the tax
deductions you got from it you have to
pay back once you get that money back
yeah and then but people are like no no
you don't got to do that yeah like I
said you could you could write your pugs
off yeah until you get audited until you
got and then when you get audited and
then they they find out that oh you
spent 150 000 on a car and you didn't
you didn't pay taxes on a blah blah blah
okay you have to pay the back taxes on
it plus penalty plus interest
so like and then if they audit you
because everything what five six years
seven years they can you know they can
like go back and be like okay hey then
that you're paying interest on like
let's say five years and then penalty
because the assumption is you're
supposed to have paid so since you're
guilty you got you would charge you
interest and penalty and that's what
that's what all that just kills you but
depending on who you're selling a car to
nobody ever really writes the True Value
they got yeah but then but if you get
audited think about what happened to
this vehicle you can't just tell them
that you sold it for 500 bucks No No
One's Gonna No One's Gonna believe that
like they'll write the receipt for a
dollar a lot of used cars people will do
that like I have a paid a dollar but
then how how could they if they're like
I don't believe you but it's on the
paper on both don't look at your bank
records
where did this hundred and twenty
thousand dollars come what if it's all
in cash and it's just in your house
that's it's up to the auditor it might
be like I don't know for sure but my
guess is up to the auditor but don't but
they at like basically they she wanted
my bank records for all the years that
she would she included the audience
yeah so she's like where's this where
did this come from where did where like
where did this go where did blah blah
blah so basically like if you did the G
wagon thing and you spent 150 000 and
then you sold it three years later for
120 it's like it's like where did the
120 come from there's a paper trail for
everything yeah oh you know from the
sale of my G wagon oh so you sold it but
you didn't pay taxes on it or you know
because that's capital gains now yeah
dude [__] hate taxes this is my first
job ever I remember when I first started
working my minimum wage I think was like
maybe 625 or seven bucks and I remember
getting like your first check and I'm
like cool I'm gonna have seven dollars
but it already has the deductions or
whatever and they're like [__] only get
[__] like 450. you're like who's
Social Security am I paying yeah yeah
I'm like God damn it I worked four hours
I get 16 isn't it funny when you were
when you were a kid like when you were
younger and you heard like on TV and in
movies there's always an old guy that
goes I paid my taxes yeah and you you it
doesn't resonate as a kid you're like
why is he always saying that that guy's
grumpy and then you get older and you're
like that is the first place your mind
goes when like some [__] happens to you
you're like this [__] up or you see
someone else that doesn't and they're
doing all this [__] [__] around
you're like oh my God like tax is the
first place your mind goes I don't like
I usually don't I usually don't talk
about taxes with people like because
people will do that like they'll be like
oh you got to write this off you gotta
do that it's like yeah but that's not
legal that's true yeah because if you've
been audited then your your perspective
is totally different yeah it's kind of
legal like those things are put in place
for like small business owners and stuff
like that to be able to get certain
braces oh no that yeah that stuff's
legal I'm talking about like people like
uh oh yeah you can you can include your
dogs in your deduction you can include
and they'll just say all these things
and the people eat it up and think oh
yeah I could do that yeah you can do all
that until you get audited and that's
true yeah audited I'm sure you're in a
pool of other people who've been audited
and you guys are all red flagged where
they're probably gonna check on those
people more because like a quick dial or
something yeah for real because this is
like well they're more successful yeah
exactly that's true yeah yeah your
perspective is way different yeah
because I hear people all the time oh
you just got to do this it's like no
it's yeah you can do that people love to
give blind advice yeah like Tick Tock is
my CPA does say like half of the tick
tock Finance information is like wrong
yeah because we're not giving the whole
context
if you did this and yes it's true if
it's specifically this case or whatever
and it's applied to nothing at all yeah
they're just like here's some stuff like
you know about the insurance thing like
so if you if you get an insurance policy
let's say for a million dollars
you can they're like The Tick Tock
things you can borrow against the
million dollars so it's like that sounds
good that's what the wealthy do they
take out these large insurance policies
and then they borrow against it which is
factual that part's factual but so I
called my insurance broker and I asked
him about it he goes okay so the here's
the issue for you to get to have a
substantial amount of insurance policy
let's say a five milligo insurance
policy you probably won't qualify for
most people won't qualify for it there's
a guy who makes I think he's like 20 30
million dollars he was having problems
getting a five million insurance policy
so the thing you can get is a one
million dollar one but let's see I
forgot what the rates were but let's
just say it's like 1500 a year for a one
million dollar insurance policy you're
you can only borrow against the fifteen
hundred dollar you put in so after 10
years you'll have 100 yeah they have a
15 000 you borrow against the fifteen
thousand it's like they're not gonna let
you borrow against them the million
dollars
yeah
so he's like no he's like what they're
saying yeah wealthy people do do that
but they have hundreds of millions of
dollars in cash so their insurance
policies let's say 5 10 million they can
borrow against that but they also have
different collateral so like he's like
no they're not telling you the whole
picture of what that makes sense because
that's the sexier part yeah if I'm a
viewer I'm like yeah that's [__] cool
I'm gonna do that this week yeah and and
most of those guys they're selling
insurance people borrow a million
dollars
no they told their friends that yo and
then most of those guys on checkout are
selling insurance policies yeah so of
course they want people to the incentive
I see those like tick tocks where like
it's like hood ass dudes and they're
talking about basically like very
blatantly not illegal but like super
unethical hacks to like get loans where
like their credit's gonna get [__] but
like it doesn't matter and it's just
crazy that people literally follow that
yeah yeah like it's like waste to like
keep borrowing from different banks like
or Max your credit card out in this way
but it's for your future it's like so
[__] but then for them it's like it
doesn't matter because they never had
the intention of having like a what is
it like an upstanding Citizen's
reputation because those people ask them
like are you planning on buying a home
no are you planning getting a car in the
next seven years no then just do this
because you know your credit will be
ruined for seven years and after that
you start over like oh okay that sounds
great yeah until something happens in
their life or like wait I do need a car
I do need this that's one of the things
that we first me and Joe first started
we were trying to deduct like crazy
because like the minute you start a
business it's like okay how do we pay as
little taxes as possible yeah so we're
deducting deducting deducting and then I
remember uh it it crossed our mind even
just like one percent like oh we should
probably buy a house or whatever and
then
um it was like hard to qualify for a
house because it showed that we haven't
made money yeah on paper you know and
then so we're like and that's what we
talked to our CPA and he's like well
then you want you need to start showing
like revenue and I'm like oh so that's
how the deductions work that's that's
the time you have to find the right
balance where yeah where you're not
paying too much taxes yeah but you're
paying enough to where the loan people
yeah yeah a crazy concept that I've
realized um lately is like you know um
for a long time now there's like young
dancers and stuff that come to LA or
like that you know they're they're
seeking advice they're like you know
what should I do and I remember when I
was doing my like later 20s my advice
was always like hustle hard work harder
than everybody in the room blah blah
blah you know motivational speech that
has nothing to do with actual real world
application now anybody who's like come
in and asking me for advice first thing
I'm sitting them down with is [__]
Financial strategy planning taxes and
understanding because if there was the
biggest one thing that I could have done
better I wish I did better in my 20s it
was being more financially illiterate so
that I could take advantage of certain
things dude if I was a dancer and I
asked you for like like advice and you
hit me with that I'd be so [__]
bummed out yeah I know because you
brought over here the hustle nobody
wants to hear it like
me when I was like 22 like anytime
somebody hit me with like Financial
advice I'd be like yeah whatever Grill
like you don't want to hear that [__]
it's like such a bummer but it's like
it's so important recently recently so I
was talking my CPA because um we're
trying to figure out like other like
because I'm trying to like get more like
houses and stuff and I was like okay so
I've been hearing this thing called
[__] cost segregation whatever like
on Tick Tock you guys know what that is
no
you can technically like portion out
different expenses to deduct against
rental income oh yeah yeah so
um what usually it is like whatever the
purchase value you can deduct almost 75
percent of it over the next 27 like
years or whatever so like let's say if
you buy a home that's like 500 G's uh
they're gonna account like 150k to the
land value but then your house is
technically falling apart the after the
day you buy it so you can deduct 350k
over like let's say approximately 30
years so that's almost like 10 to 12 G's
yeah a year you can deduct so if you
make rental income that's even a grand a
month which is 12 G's a year on paper it
shows like you made zero money so you
pay zero taxes but in your bank account
you're stacking 12 G's every year so I
was like interesting I was like how come
they don't [__] teach this [__] I
want you to know right yeah and I'm like
and then I was like damn like taxes
should be like the first thing you learn
either in college or or maybe they did
teach me if I wasn't paying attention
but they don't want people to be good at
taxes well the way to do it too is also
if you sit down with that 22 year old
Nick and you're like dude you got to get
your financial literacy out that's
boring as [__] but if you're like hey
actually uh because I saved on taxes and
I did is I bought this car you know what
I mean and it's like oh wow that's cool
that's the biggest difference is like I
have had people talk to me that way when
I was younger but they didn't have proof
in their own life that's the big
difference it's like they're they're
just saying it yeah but it's like the
people that are practicing it and can
show the results they're just I don't
know them they didn't have enough
Rolexes to like yeah and then they take
it off and give it back to the person
who gave it to them yeah like it's just
for the video I told a young comic um
because I talk about money all the time
I go like hey like I understand this
thing about being hungry and it makes
you work harder that's cool but you also
gotta eat and you have to have a roof
over your so I told one coming I go
you're white you can move anywhere in
the country you don't have to stay in
L.A because it's hard for comics in La
you can move in your one thing for use
like I asked him what his degree was in
school he's not one of those he could he
wanted to go to a trade school go join
the elevators Union
because you can get work all over the
country it's guaranteed work there's
elevator workers have a union you work
during the day which means in night time
you can go perform stand-up and wherever
you work wherever you move to there's a
club and you be you be the host of the
club that the resident hosts but
meanwhile in the daytime you're making
money because you need money like if you
don't have if you that stress of money
is gone it allows you to write up and I
know there's a flip side of like oh
you're more hungry okay cool but if you
if you enjoy not eating you enjoy
Couchsurfing cool go for it but if you
also enjoy eating and like having to
move over your head figure a way out to
work during the day yeah and then work
at night people love to romanticize like
the rags to riches yeah success type of
story yeah yeah people love that [__]
but if you look at overrated though
isn't it yeah artists be starving though
yeah for sure if you look at sex stack
has 100 with 30 000 union members less
than one percent make all the money what
practical person is gonna like be go
into that going gonna make it no chances
are you're not less than one percent
it's crazy you still gotta pay your 3
000 Initiation fee oh yeah when you
start out yeah because like if you one
percent 125 is 1250 people less than
that make all like pretty much all the
money that comes out yeah like Tom
Cruise that makes sense even with dance
agents like dance agents are like I
always ask them like Hey how do you guys
make enough money like uh because I had
friends that would work for them and
they're like you just need like five
Heavies and everybody else is just they
already know that they're not gonna
bring money in that's why they signed so
many dancers you know they're just like
they don't get numbers [__] they're just
like you just need like a Tabitha and a
Napoleon and you're good like you just
need some heavies
Heavies you just need to fix some
elevators I thought you were talking
about tits at the beginning